all right God logic what's up bro what's
up man nothing much how you doing
tonight I'm pretty good man I'm pretty
good just was uh hungry for some
entertainment you know nothing really
good was was on you know I was a
searching the live so I just went live
myself okay so um couple weeks ago I
heard you talking about Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and you called him a
war you called him what was it not a
warmonger but a war war criminal you
talked about Aisha you talked about
stealing stuff and I just had some
issues about the uh some things I wanted
you to resolve for me in the Bible as it
relates to those things you just said is
that all right wait wait hold on so do
you affirm that I was correct about
Muhammad and those things and that he's
wrong and that you're saying that there
may be some things in the Bible that are
also
wrong I'm saying that those things that
you mentioned are in the Bible and can
be based on your logic applied to Jesus
Christ okay no problem so if uh they're
applied to Jesus Christ then Jesus would
be wrong and and immoral is that correct
certainly so so then you agree with me
that Muhammad is immoral the things that
you said about you you said he was a war
criminal you mentioned Aisha you
mentioned uh things that he had done in
war things like that and you're asking
me if I think those things are immoral
um yes what I'm going to say is that I
stud stud history and I understand moral
or or cultural and ethical relativism so
for me to judge a man who lived 1400
1500 years ago based on my standards
would not be correct so again it's a
it's a little bit of here or there well
I'm not asking according to your
standards obviously I believe that
morality is objective I don't believe
it's subjective and you're a theist like
I am so we both believe in objective
morality not cult uh culture or or
relative morality we don't believe in
that we believe in objective morality
you you and I so right but there's a go
ahead so like so just for example um 400
years ago are are you a black man if I'm
if you don't mind me asking yes I am all
right so you're just like me uh you
American yes all right so we're both
black Americans right 400 years ago they
had taken our people and enslaved them
uh graped their wives their mothers
their daughters separated their families
and beat their families beat the men in
front of their families to emasculate
them 400 years ago this just happened
was that can you can you judge that as
wrong to do would I judge that as wrong
to do again if I as a historian are to
exercise cultural and E and U ethical
relativism that side of me would say I'd
have to judge it based on that context
and whether in that context those things
were morally and culturally wrong me
right now the way I feel absolutely I
think it's wrong so uh again you don't
you're a theist you believe in a God
right yes done time or culture or
majority people again absolutely as a
historian yes I'd have to say yes okay
so all right when is when is grape ever
okay again um I wouldn't say I mean
again as a 21st century human being it's
never okay but if I were wait wait
that's that's not wait you're you're
saying in as a 21st century human being
so you can't say never when you're only
in the 21st century is there ever a
century where grape is okay so that so
you know what you just did you just
appealed to objective morality not
cultural relativism okay but the the the
subject that you used is such a bait you
guys love us you love you guys love
using grape and children and things like
that that way if the person disagrees
with it then you go oh look this person
and blah blah blah no that that's not
the well that well that's well that's
that's on you man you you you can be
honest and say yeah you know what yeah
great in depending on the time or
culture if if it was okay in their
culture to great people then yes it's
okay for them you know you you can say
that and then you know you you you know
you'll have the the consequence of how
you're viewed later but stand on it if
that's your view but if you know it's
wrong then that is not call it out that
is not my view absolutely wrong I I know
I'm not saying it's I'm not saying it's
your view my brother I'm saying that if
you if you're going to have if you're
going to stand on cultural relativism
then you have to be okay with grape
depending on culture if there's a
culture that doesn't condemn grape and
people are doing it you you as a
cultural Rel relativist can't condemn it
but you do condemn it because you're not
a cultural Rel relativist you believe in
objective morality so stop pretending
like you're a cultural relativist cuz
you're not a a men can have dualities
correct you can be one thing and you can
be two things at once so I as a
historian exercise cultural and ethical
relativism and of course as a
God-fearing man a God-fearing Muslim
absolutely agree with objective morality
but let's get to the argument how about
that because what you just said well
this this is the argument we well we had
to settle that first cuz we could move
we couldn't move forward with you you
know dabbling and and and on the fence
of this we have to come to a foundation
and understand that morality is based on
God it's beyond human you know uh humans
don't determine what what is good or
what is bad neither does time determine
what is good or what is bad right it's
objective it is beyond us we don't
decide that God does okay so so with you
understand if it's objective then this
would what the things that you just
mentioned grape are in the Bible and as
a matter of fact it's prescribed by the
Christian God and are and are condemned
no no no no this is prescribed by the
Christian God of the Bible I have
evidence okay all right that's that's
fine but let's let's let's even you know
what cuz if you just going to just say
that
fine so if you're saying that grape is
is prescribed then that would mean it's
immoral correct what what go ahead I'm
sorry repeat that one more time that
would mean isal 100% okay so whatever is
sanctioning grape is an immoral
prescription right all right what about
adultery sleeping with another man's
wife or a wife sleeping with another
woman's husband or you know just
stepping out on your on your wife at all
is that that imoral according to the
Bible period just is that a moral
certainly I'll give you that yes it's a
moral very good is child abuse or child
molestation or sexual relations with
children is that immoral of course yes
it however those things are in the Bible
described by the Christian God no
worries no no worries no worries so the
things that I said about Muhammad him
being a war criminal allowing adultery
and also grape when it comes to uh
pillaging Villages specifically at the
the people of altas and then also
prescribing and sanctioning child
relations he did it himself and it's
also in the Quran you would agree that
Muhammad is an immoral person right cuz
you're saying it's in the Bible too fine
so the Bible and Muhammad both are
immoral characters right again I think
you're trying to get me to say something
about Prophet Muhammad and then you're
going to say oh see according to this
you're now this because you said this
about Prophet no stop stop you're over
you're overthinking we're just having a
conversation you're overthinking I'm
just trying to have you be consistent
you're you're asking me if I agree that
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is an
immoral person based on these things
that you have set out I don't have
evidence of those things existing so no
I do not I only have evidence of those
things existing in the Bible as
prescribed by the Christian God of the
Bible okay all right so you you said
that you saw me say these things uh a
few weeks ago and you didn't listen to
the evidence that I brought up um I I
think I ended up I missed it I heard you
you were just kind of on the attack some
Muslim came up he kind of pissed you off
and uh you kind of went on the attack
for a minute and then I think I kind of
didn't um get the rest of it I heard
what I heard and then I heard you say
something today also that kind of aderes
to the Bible so yeah you're very
biblical I'll give you that okay so um
let's do what the let's do with the
adultery one first wait wait are we
going to get my argument first Muhammad
well well we're dealing with your
argument you said that you know the
things that I said about Muhammad also
applies to the Bible so and I'm trying
to I'm trying to ask you okay are these
things immoral in the Bible you said yes
so then I asked you okay so then you
would agree that Muhammad and the Bible
are both wrong right you said well I
haven't seen these things about Muhammad
so I'm about to show you and I'll show
you my biblical examples of of what's in
the Bible yeah we we we we could go over
the Bible but let me let me show you
that Muhammad is so that that so that
you can you can you know say that how
about thisam if we want to be
historically accurate the Bible predates
Muhammad so maybe I should present mine
first it sure does no no no that's not
that's not how this goes you came here
saying Avery you said this this and this
about Muhammad but there's also these
things that these same things in your
Bible so I asked you well is that a
problem are you saying that these things
that you're saying are in the Bible are
wrong you said absolutely so then I
asked you okay so then you agree that
both Muhammad and the Bible are wrong
then are both immoral you was willing to
say that about the Bible but not about
Muhammad based on the fact that you said
you haven't seen these things about
Muhammad so let's establish that and
then allow you to have a fair chance to
compare
okay so dealing with adultery go go
really quick cuz I'm you know I don't
have access to stuff but go to chapter I
only have my Bible in front of me is
that is that okay how do you only have
your Bible I'm reading Myan it's uh it's
somewhere in this house um you want me
to get my laptop possibly get something
man I just I want you to so what do you
want quran.com correct what whatever
whatever you go with whatever helps what
whatever helps man and if we're talking
about again his historically if this
stuff was in the Bible 600 years before
Muhammad was born one can just say he's
following the Bible technically go ahead
which which which would make him wrong
which makes the Bible wrong right which
would make then Muhammad for following
the Bible that
has look at you if if Muhammad is
following the Bible that has these
immoral teachings and acts and Muhammad
is doing these things following the
Bible then he's also wrong right I want
you to present your all right I'm on
quran.com do you which one where do I go
go to chapter 4 verse
24 chapter 4 verse 24 and then make a
how long a m man how many likes is a m
oh I never even thought of that I ain't
think if it that work okay 424 man you
got you there yet right what what it say
really you going to really focus on the
beginning of the verse you can read all
the rest man but the the beginning of
the verse is what we going to be
thinking about man if you want context
also you could you could read verse 23
too man help you out so basically let me
help you though it's um it's talking
about the type of women that are
forbidden for the Muslim men like the
type of women you can't have relations
with the mentions a mother you know
auntie and stuff like that um so it's
talking about women that are forbidden
for you and then it mentions in 23 I'm
I'm sorry in 24 also married women are
forbidden for you except so go ahead and
read the verse all right
to you are all Beyond these as long as
you seek them with your wealth in legal
marriage not in fornication hold on bro
you didn't read the beginning ofden are
married women accept female captives in
your possession is that what you're
talking about that's what I'm talking
about right there so then it talks about
how all others other than those are just
lawful for them as long as they seek
them you know the right way or whatever
but that part right there is what I'm
focused on married women are forbidden
for these men except the female slaves
who they capture so these female slaves
that they're capturing are married yet
they're still allowed to commit they're
allowed to commit adultery with them are
you I I think you're reaching a little
bit it says it simply says female
captives in your position what are they
they're married right okay well
according to the text one can assume
that yes because of the way it's yes
exactly it's almost like I it's almost
as if I say um uh forbidden for you are
all snacks in the cabinet except except
the Doritos which are in the cab well
the Doritos are exactly exactly so so
this says forbidden are all married
women huh make a right I am making a
right it says wait wait a minute I think
I think you're potentially reading this
incorrect bro I got to I got to the way
the way okay so also forbidden or or
married women except right saying female
captiv do you know the the term captive
predates the word slave so he's clearly
saying slaves in your
position they're married Bro that's the
point who cares if they're captives or
slaves they're married how a slave and
these men are able to capture them again
you'd have to back up your evidence that
these females here that you're talking
about in the sentence are actual
captives married captives or married
slaves dude I let's for forget captives
and slaves if you're if you're if you're
caught up on that that's not nothing for
you to be caught up on I want you to
focus on the part that it says that all
married women are forbidden except the
captive slaves or the female slaves or
the female captive whatever you to call
wrong they're married women okay so tell
me how it's wrong bro cuz I mean Common
Sense bro let's use com reading
comprehension let's not also forbidden
are married women that is the one type
of woman that are forbidden except
female captives that is the second group
of of women that are no they're in the
same category of married okay if I I'mma
bring the same example to you I say all
snacks all snacks in the cabinet are
forbidden for you except the Doritos
does that mean that the Doritos are not
part of the category of s i don't that
that's a that's a false analogy I don't
think I don't think and and how tell me
how it's a false analogy break it down
the reason because what you're saying
your example and this example are to are
are hly different
again don't just tell me that break down
how my analogy fails okay your analogy
fails because it's not consistent with
this right here again telling me in
another way that my analogy doesn't work
is not actually telling me how my
analogy doesn't work so again tell me
how my analogy fails is inconsistent
doesn't work okay so you are saying also
forbidden are married women one category
except female captives second category
this he's talking about married women
who are married to other men and then
female captives who are a group of this
is two different distinct groups who are
mared all right my brother do do me this
favor okay cuz uh I'm giving you a lot
of Grace right now okay I'll Grant you
what you want let's just move forward I
feel I feel I feel like I feel like
you're playing games I'm not playing
games with you but it's okay I'm I'm I'm
in a good M I'm in a good mood is this
this right here go ahead and go in babe
in order what do you want um just give
me give me some regular tacos I guess
you want what I yeah I got get what you
get I'm I'm in here cooking man I'm
going just stay right here all right
brother you're still under your computer
right all right go to sun.com for me
just open open another tab don't go on
that same tab keep that same keep that
tab of the Quran open and incidentally
what you just mentioned is also in the
Bible nice and I can prove it right here
right now okay I'm at tuna.com put in
the search bar you see the Sear bar put
in alas a w t a s okay we got some cap
on the day of Alas and they had husbands
among their okay all right there you go
there's your proof touche tou see how
married this is what I was asking for
you logic you have to present evidence
buddy your your name is logic you have
to present evidence to back up what
you're saying otherwise that sentence
could have been talking about two
different distinct groups of females I
brought up I brought up the kran
I brought up the Quran and unfortunately
I keep forgetting that the Quran for
Muslims isn't evidence the Quran isn't
evidence Muslims a matter of fact you
need the holy you need the Holy Spirit
to understand the Quran that's that's
why I don't know what that means but
let's go forward with this argument it
means that unless you have the spirit of
God living in you you will not be able
to be honest with the Quran verses again
you just won't get it that that's that's
irrelevant but that's fine let's move on
so what what was your point that's in
that's in that's in the gospel of logic
21 but look so all right so you see how
they are married and they're captives
right and all right and the men they
capture these married women and they're
able to sleep with them the Quran says
corre they're able to have them
according to what I just saw so right so
they are allowed to commit adultery with
them with these type of married women
specifically not any others not any free
woman not any Muslim woman but with
these women who are married they are
allowed to commit adultery and this is
all in the Bible also and I'll prove it
tonight so just to be so just to be
clear just to be clear just just just to
be clear ma earlier you said that
adultery is immoral period so you agree
that the Quran is permitting something
that is immoral again according to what
you just said according to this of
course I'd have to research it a little
further I can't just take your I can't
just take but okay man I just I it ain't
my words but I gave you the words of the
Quran based on what you just presented
certainly so then if you with you
understanding this how the Quran is
permitting adultery and you are
recognizing that it's wrong why are you
still following wa wait wait wait wait
let's uh okay but why are you still
following the Bible the Bible has a very
similar I mean can I get to it we'll get
to it once we finish this why when you
when you just recog reced that the Quran
is teaching something immoral something
sinful why are you still againe my same
question to you the Bible also teaches
the same immoral acts that are condoned
and in fact instructed by the Christian
God of the Bible why are you still a
Christian I heard the claim brother
brother I I heard the claim that
doesn't once I once we here the hear
this brother hear this hear this and
hear this carefully okay you said you've
been watching me so you've seen how I do
things answer the question let's finish
this topic and then we'll I'll let you
bring your issue with the Bible on this
subject got is that fair okay so since
you recognized that this is a moral
teaching being permitted in the Quran by
Allah why do you still follow it again I
I don't have an answer for that question
but I but your points are all taken your
points are valid I will look into what
do you mean I'm I'm in I'm in I'm within
my I'm in my study so I can't you know I
have to read the totality of the Bible
and the Quran to get to solid you don't
need to read the totality you don't need
to read the totality of the Quran or the
Bible to un to know that this is wrong
which you which you acknowledged so the
only question is why are you following
something that is giving moral commands
never said that was or what okay sorry
I'm I lost my thought um it's it's okay
Happ you cannot read one paragraph in a
book and expect to understand the entire
book am I correct you don't need to I
say that that I didn't I'm not I'm not
bringing in I'm not bringing in the
entire understanding of the full Quran
elsewhere because that's a relevant here
I'm focusing on one particular you agree
that if I read one part of a book that I
would know that the full know what that
book was talking about I would not right
I I think that if you read one part of
the book and you saw that this part of
the book taught immoral evil things you
don't need to see the rest of the book
to know that it's not from God logic you
know that's you know that's incorrect
say stop you okay so so let me answer so
so answer me this do you believe that
the book from God can have immoral
commands or teachings from from God have
a moral teachings the Bible does you
don't is the Bible book to you correct
yes no no I I'm just asking period is
the Bible the book from God according to
Christians yes it is a Divine book is it
am I not my my fiance just told me to
give you one last chance so I'm gonna do
it I'm G get I'm G listen to my
beautiful I can't even present my
argument bro I think you're doing this
on purpose you're dragging see the thing
the thing is my my my toxic friend the
the more that you are dishonest the
longer this takes
the quicker you are honest the quicker
we can move on to the Bible I promise
you baby isn't that how I do that's how
I do quicker you're
honest C oh nice so the quicker you're
honest the quicker we can move to the
very subject you want to pull up and I'm
I have no problem addressing it just be
honest so we can move forward okay so
here we are again is the Bible the book
of God so you believe that the Bible is
the word of God so you so I'm just I'm
just confused man I'm I'm not going to
lie man Bible is not the word of God I
mean I believe the Bible is the word of
God but you a Muslim the Bible is the
word of God what what's the problem it
says right here the Lord said so you you
you say it say the Lord said hold on
brother I mean I hear you brother but so
you telling me man that you believe that
the Bible is the word of God man yes the
the word of God Bible is the Bible is
not I don't understand I don't
understand what you want all right so
you so you believe in the crucifixion
man I do I do not believe that Jesus was
crucified I don't believe in the come on
man let me ask you this man let me ask
you this do the bible teach that Jesus
was crucified man in the Bible the word
of God yes the Bible's the word of God
what's the problem I don't get it so the
B so the word of God ser Jesus was
crucified man yes but you don't
believe believing and reading are two
different things I can read the Bible as
a reader and say that this is the word
of God because it says the Lord said
blank blank blank what's the big deal
but you so so you telling me right now
man that you openly deny word like you
you deny the word you have you just you
look bro listen to me man listen listen
to me real carefully man brother you
literally just said man the Bible the
word of God man you also you also
acknowledge that the bible teach the
crucifixion of Jesus corre what do you
say you don't believe in the CR what
does my belief have to do with reading
the words in a book if I read Harry
Potter would that make me like a wizard
or something because I do I believe in
Wizards because I read Harry Potter I
read the book I'm a
reader All right but I hear you I hear
you toxic but listen to here man there's
a I agree with you that there's a
difference man between acknowledging
something and then actually believe two
different things
buddy your reading and believing are two
different things look brother brother
brother that's what I'm saying I'm
saying I see where you coming from man
that's what I'm saying I see where you
coming from so you you acknowledge that
the Bible word is is this a joke all
right I'm I think you're in a you're in
a DA mood man I think I'm gonna I'm
going to go ahead and that's fine uh you
know I'm going to I'll just I'll seek
I'll seek out other Christians for them
to uh see if they can resolve these evil
things that the Christian God of the
Bible um has prescribed to people
because I'm pretty I'm pretty sure you
don't have an answer I don't scared you
off man I don't you're joking you're
playing you're joking and playing you're
prolonging this cuz you know you don't
want to get to my evidence because you
have no answer for it I think I think
that you trying to run away from where
where this really lead to man
okay talking you know you're talking in
this Dopey slang what am I real am I
real voice man that's my real voice man
all right logic what you here laughing
at man now now now I'm feeling offended
all right bro take it easy man take it
easy man I hope to see you soon
man feel I'm not going to lie I I
understand where bro coming from there's
a difference between acknowledging and
believing it where's life but for some
reason this man just denied the word of
God man and didn't want to admit it what
we what we doing here man I mean
somebody come tell me what we doing